this is the front line of the epidemic
in Wuhan and it is bleak we cannot
verify the status of the people under
the sheets it is a crowded chaotic and
terrifying scene one that shows what
doctors nurses and patients are enduring
together the footage is at odds with the
efforts on the ground portrayed by state
media this is the extraordinary sight of
a new 1000 bed hospital being built from
scratch in less than a week the
infrastructure propaganda that is a
symbol of China's rise repurposed for an
epidemic state media also focused on the
bravery and hard work of medical staff
in women are bit in more sanitized
conditions what worries us most is the
inconvenience caused to local residents
although we have taken some counter
measures to alleviate this situation
there are still many difficulties we aim
to use the temporary inconvenience in
exchange for long-standing safety Lu Han
itself has been cut off for more than 36
hours now people are stocking up on
supplies because they simply do not know
how long they'll be on their own when
the officially said ok close down the
roads close down our transport that's
when everybody started really getting
serious about it and we are started to
wear the masks in public and carry hand
sanitizer with us in the neighboring
province it was a very different picture
we got out of Wuhan just before the
travel ban came into effect we drove
about three hours north here to shinyang
and it's no smoother even though it's
just over the border people are a lot
more relaxed a lot of them are not
wearing face masks they are a bit
nervous but they're not panics at all
you're not wearing a mask those busy
just now and I forgot about the masks
but I should really wear it that one
wrong I'm paying attention to the
situation I feel the country is doing
great but here like many places in China
face masks were difficult to come by
now the masks are sold out for days
already like this morning just within
about one hour we had a dozen people
coming in to ask if we have masks
concerning south of Wuhan authorities
turned to talk
into checkpoints they measured people's
body temperatures anyone with a high
reading was sent to hospital in the
capital Beijing to televise celebrations
for Lunar New Year a choreographed
months in advance this was an
uncharacteristic last-minute addition
the tribute to doctors and a rallying
cry to the country it must have felt a
world away in Wuhan